à peine Stéphane a-t-il rejoint sa place
que François s'est levé
un patient de venir s'exprimer un
patient de venir nous proposer une
vision une analyse un propos sur la
situation actuelle la situation
politique mais pas seulement la
situation politique je suis très heureux
Mesdames et Messieurs que François soit
là aujourd'hui pour beaucoup de raisons
qui seraient trop longue à développer il
y en a qui sont très conjoncturels et
qui tiennent à sa présence aujourd'hui
et vous en dira un mot et puis il y en a
qui tiennent au fait que depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois plusieurs
années nous sommes engagés dans un
combat politique pacifique démocratique
mais dans un combat politique commun
nous voulons construire avec nos
partenaires de la majorité les
conditions qui nous permettent de faire
avancer le pays qui permettent de
traiter au fond les sujets qui
permettent de préparer l'avenir et nous
nous retrouvons parfaitement dans cette
dans ce combat commun alors je suis très
heureux très heureux d'accueillir
François Béraud et je vous demande de
lui réserver un tonnerre laudissements
allez
merci beaucoup
bon je vais tout de suite lever le voile
sur le mystère que Édouard
fenêtre disait comme on dit en franglais
en effet je partirai à 16h et ça n'est
en aucune manière pour une raison de
un confort ou de mésentente avec les
orateurs qui s'exprimeront à cette
ce moment là c'est parce que c'est le
match de rugby du siècle
entre pot et Bayonne
et je ne sais pas si vous j'espère que
vos applaudissements s'adressent à la
Section Paloise mais
c'est un match qui va se dérouler dans
des conditions
exceptionnelles extraordinaire
puisqu'ils vont se dérouler à
Saint-Sébastien dans le grand stade à
newetta devant 39000 personnes derby
devant 39000 personnes et donc j'irai
regarder le match je n'y serais pas ce
qui est une trahison de mes amis qu'ils
ont beaucoup de mal à me pardonner mais
je vais au moins ne manquer aucune
minute de ce match c'est la raison pour
laquelle je m'échapperai le plus
discrètement possible et je vous prie de
ni voir qu'une marque de
fidélité à mes racines
[Applaudissements]
c'est un pardon que vous avez exprimé
par ces par ces applaudissements bon
c'est une journée très importante pour
vous
et nous sommes très sensibles
mode Gatel la députée de Paris
secrétaire général du Mouvement
Démocrate et moi à votre invitation et
ce n'est pas moi qui vous dirais jamais
qu'il est facile de construire un
nouveau parti c'est une des tâches les
plus exigeantes qui soient
de construire c'est difficile
et le faire durer et grandir c'est
encore plus difficile
et nous avons tous l'expérience moi j'ai
des souvenirs formidables je regarde
Philippe Augier dans cette salle
longtemps
nous avons fait ça
et je sais ce qu'il faut d'enthousiasme
et ce qu'il faut de temps et ce qu'il
faut de sédimentation et c'est pourquoi
nos vœux vous accompagnent je voulais
les exprimer à cette tribune
nous avons une grande responsabilité
ensemble
lorsque Richard Ferrand qui est là-bas
que je serai heureux que nous
applaudissions tous ensemble
Richard qui
était à l'époque président de
l'Assemblée nationale scherienne
ton prédécesseur lorsque Richard Ferrand
Édouard Philippe et moi nous avons
eu la charge de dessiner une
organisation
qui nous rassemble après la victoire
d'Emmanuel Macron la réélection
d'Emmanuel Macron
que tant d'observateurs mettait en doute
et qui a dit quelque chose du choix
profond du pays sur son avenir et après
la nomination d'Elisabeth borne
à Matignon madame la Première ministre
lorsque nous avons eu cette charge le
nom que nous avons choisi c'est ensemble
et c'est parce que nous pressentions
déjà que dans la tempête qui
s'approchait
il n'y aurait pas d'autres issues pour
les membres de la majorité que la
solidarité
et je veux réaffirmer
cet engagement cette ligne de conduite
même en sachant que cet idéal n'a été
pour l'instant
comment dire inégalement respecté
mais moi je suis David de Churchill
que nous aimons beaucoup
qui disait on reconnaît un grand
politique à sa capacité à prédire
l'avenir
à définir les stratégies pour
l'atteindre
et après coup à pouvoir expliquer
pourquoi pourquoi rien de tout cela n'a
marché
et donc
je veux rappeler que même si ça a été
inégalement accompli
la mission la ligne de conduite
elle est intacte et je veux rappeler
aussi pour compléter Churchill
modestement humblement qu'on reconnaît
un vrai politique non seulement à sa
capacité de comprendre
les enjeux mais
s'il se casse la figure 999 fois sur le
chômage à se relever pour recommencer
une millième choix et reprendre le calme
et je suis sûr
que les moments que nous vivons ne nous
laisse pas d'autres choix que
d'accomplir la promesse que nous avons à
cette époque formulée
l'intuition d'ensemble
elle est plus justifiée plus nécessaire
aujourd'hui 25 mars
qu'elle ne l'était encore au moment où
nous avons Richard Édouard et moi et
ceux qui travaillaient avec nous dont un
certain nombre sont dans cette salle
nous avons décidé de la réaliser
et cela pour deux grandes séries de
raisons que je veux rappeler devant vous
la première est que
nous sommes la seule
majorité cohérente possible pour
l'avenir du pays la seule majorité tout
à l'heure Stéphane a dit majorité
relative nous sommes une majorité
relative mais nous sommes la seule
majorité possible et c'est apparu de
manière éclatante au moment du débat sur
la réforme des retraites et de manière
éclatante au moment de la motion de
censure
alors ça ne veut pas dire que nous
sommes d'accord sur tout
ensemble ça ne veut pas dire
unanimisme qui efface les identités les
différences et les histoires
et puis dans les 20 dernières années si
on cherchait bien on trouverait
probablement quelques sujets
qui nous ont parfois
permis d'exprimer des nuances
depuis 2002 jusqu'à 2023 il y en a eu
quelques-uns
nous n'avons pas toujours été du même
avis et probablement de le seront pas
encore sur la ligne exacte à suivre mais
dans les jours que nous vivons
dans les années que nous avons à
affronter il y a une chose que nous
devons regarder en face
dans l'incertitude
dans l'inquiétude du pays qui a été
abordé à cette tribune et qui va l'être
encore
face aux menaces qui viennent sur lui et
face au menaces que parfois il se crée
lui-même
alors le devoir de chacun d'entre nous
et de nous rassembler pour prendre en
charge les grands enjeux de notre destin
commun
jamais
depuis longtemps chacun d'entre nous l'a
en tête jamais depuis longtemps nous
n'avons eu à faire face à une telle
accumulation de menaces extérieures la
guerre le changement climatique la crise
énergétique l'inflation la guerre
commerciale sans merci et de menaces
intérieure l'école en péril la santé qui
doute les finances publiques au bout de
la logique de la dette
la démocratie qui chancelle
la violence aveugle chez nous et dans la
vie publique
la violence s'offront pas
qui fait même que des barbares se
risquent à écrire
je le dis pour Aurore berger
ce risque à écrire à des députés qui
viennent d'être maman pour proférer des
menaces contre leur bébé qui vient de
naître
[Applaudissements]
la démocratie
qui est discutée partout dans le monde
et qui chez nous-mêmes encourt le
reproche d'inefficacité
au moment où cette crise s'est
déclenchée
j'ai risqué et beaucoup de mes amis
m'ont dit quand même te exagères un peu
j'ai risqué que
cette crise s'était probablement la
crise la plus dure que nous aurions à
affronter depuis la guerre
et aujourd'hui je pense toujours que
c'est la plus implacable des vérités
et alors que cherche-t-on quand les
temps s'assombrissent comme ça on
cherche l'espoir
et on cherche la volonté
nous savons ce que nous sommes sommes
comme un grand peuple
forgé dans l'histoire et dans un idéal
l'idéal républicain et humaniste dont la
vocation était et toujours universel
et ce projet a fait naître
un peuple néant vital un élan de
transmission
un élan de recherche un élan de
découverte une confiance en nous-même
c'est tout cela qui est en péril
aujourd'hui
c'est tout cela qu'on a vu au fil du
temps s'affaiblir
au fil du temps se fragiliser
et c'est de cela de la renaissance de
cet élan vital que nous avons ensemble
la charge
parce que
représentons-nous les bancs de
l'Assemblée nationale
quelles autres courants démocratiques
que le nôtre
quelle autre ensemble de courant avec
ses affluences
peuvent prétendre à relever cet élan à
rassembler le pays
à faire à nouveau monter la sève de
notre histoire à renouer avec le courage
et le goût de vivre ensemble qui peut
s'allier avec qui
pour s'avancer avec courage à la tête de
ce peuple
réconcilié avec lui-même
et quand vous posez la question de cette
manière alors vous ne trouvez que
de rares ou de seuls prétendants
ce sont les deux expressions politiques
qui prétendent jouer ce rôle ce sont les
deux extrêmes qui n'hésitent plus à
s'allier ensemble et avec quelques
supplétifs pour abattre l'oeuvre que
nous avons entreprises de redressement
national
or il y a une chose
qui est une certitude pour qui
a tourné un jour les pages d'un livre
d'histoire où connait un peu ce qui est
arrivé à notre pays
une seule certitude
jamais dans l'histoire
jamais dans notre histoire nationale
jamais dans l'histoire de l'Europe
jamais dans l'histoire du monde
l'extrémisme la culture de la division
la malédiction portée contre les
adversaires de ces idéologies jamais
l'extrémisme l'extrémisme diviseur
l'extrémisme qui ne cesse de surenchérir
sur sa propre colère sa propre
détestation sa propre violence verbale
d'abord et après physique jamais
l'extrémisme n'a donné à un peuple à
quelque peuples que ce soit
l'épanouissement et le bonheur jamais
quelques quelques extrémisme que ce soit
car ce poison s'empoisonne lui-même et
empoisonne tout ce qu'il touche
irrémédiablement
et si nous avons conscience de cela
conscience d'être
la seule
possibilité la seule majorité de
rassemblement
capable
d'organiser
la vie du pays pour que son redressement
s'accomplisse
si nous apprécions comme nous sommes
nous respectons comme nous sommes nous
sommes décidés à faire fructifier ce
patrimoine commun de liberté et de
conscience qui est le nôtre alors le
devoir qui est devant nous est
impossible à éluder c'est notre
responsabilité
alors ne me faites pas dire ce que je
n'ai pas dit je n'ai pas dit que nous
avons été que nous sommes parfaits
je n'ai pas dit que nous n'avons pas
fait d'erreur ni ne nous avons corrigé
nos insuffisances ni que nous n'en
ferons pas dans l'avenir je dis que
notre mission
la seule de nos missions et de ne rien
lâcher de ce que nous croyons de ne rien
lâcher de notre volonté d'équilibre de
notre volonté de nous affirmer généreux
en même temps que réaliste lucide en
même temps que optimiste et je n'ai pas
dit en même temps tout à fait par hasard
il y a une énergie à réveiller et si
nous ne le faisons pas qui le fera et où
cette énergie s'égarera-t-elle si nous
ne tenons pas fermement la barre
alors il est vrai
que toute perspective d'élargissement je
t'ai entendu Édouard
et tu vas j'imagine réaborder ce sujet
dans ton intervention toute perspective
d'élargissement est bonne
mais il n'y aura d'élargissement que si
nous sommes forts nous
ensemble
conscience de ce que nous sommes
déterminés si nous sommes capables de
nous rassembler d'abord nous-mêmes avant
ou en même temps que nous proposerons à
d'autres j'espère qu'ils existent de se
rassembler avec nous c'est en nous c'est
dans nos rang c'est dans notre majorité
quelle inspiration et qu'elle a force
c'est là que nous devons trouver
l'énergie nécessaire pour affronter
l'avenir qui vient
c'est à cet instant que le dialogue que
nous pourrons nouer avec d'autres
d'inspiration différente pour apporter
ses fruits
mais ce dialogue ne portera pas ses
fruits si nous n'avons pas conscience
nous-mêmes si nous ne croyons pas
nous-mêmes en ce que nous disons et si
nous ne trouvons pas les mots et le
style pour faire partager au pays les
convictions qui nous ont formées et
forgées
alors ça veut dire que évidemment il y a
devant nous des missions très
importantes je voudrais un aborder une
ou deux simplement la première
il faut que nous trouvions que nous
inventions que nous réinventions que
nous retrouvions
la méthode de la réforme
la réforme à la française ou la réforme
pour la France
on est
profondément troublé quand on voit à
quel point dans notre pays tout œuvre de
réforme
est à l'instant combattu
niait dans son inspiration et sa
nécessité démolie
or ce n'est pas une fatalité
parce qu'il va bien falloir que sur tous
les grands sujets qui font le souci du
pays
nous acceptions
d'imaginer des voies nouvelles et de les
proposer au pays
j'ai une conviction je prétends pas que
tout le monde la partage
moi je crois
que la démocratie c'est plus puissant
qu'on imagine
la plupart des gens voient dans la
démocratie des limites des insuffisances
et des faiblesses
moi je crois que si on parvient
changer le point de vue
à considérer que la réforme elle doit
être préparée avec les citoyens et pas
seulement décider pour eux
ça dépasse une démarche verticale
si nous arrivons à considérer que chacun
des citoyens est partenaire
des mots classiques
peuple à sa part de pouvoir
si nous parvenons à
proposer à partager
avec le peuple de citoyens dont nous
avons la responsabilité les raisons les
plus profondes les plus nets les plus
chiffrées s'il le faut la nécessité de
changer les choses alors on peut trouver
du soutien je ne crois pas
vous avez le droit d'applaudir ça
j'accepte
[Applaudissements]
on en a pas l'habitude la plupart des
temps on y croit pas
et moi je crois que chacun des Français
comme père mère de famille travailleur
retraitée peut partager les raisons de
cela pardon pour ceux qui m'ont entendu
dire ça 150 fois mais
en tout cas je crois que c'est une des
voies possibles pour inventer la réforme
à la française
aller plus loin dans le partage des
raisons et dans la réflexion partagée
et puis je vais finir en disant
où on décrivant une mission très
importante et très difficile et en
employant un mot qui n'est pas souvent
utilisé en politique moi je crois que
nous devons
définir
réécrire
quelque chose qui manque profondément et
sans lequel la vie politique et la vie
démocratique sont deviennent absolument
impossibles et totalement enlisée nous
devons
réécrire un idéal pour notre pays je
crois pas à l'action sans idéal
et trop souvent on a l'impression que
l'idéal s'efface derrière la gestion or
je crois que la gestion si elle est bien
inspirée ne peut être qu'une application
de cet idéal qui nous rassemble et qui
nous réunit c'est par un idéal
démocratique réinventée que nous
trouverons le chemin des consciences et
peut-être aussi des cœurs merci beaucoup
merci
merci François
merci François pour ce discours qui
qui provoque
[Musique]
chez Horizon ce que nous aimons c'est à
dire réfléchir
songer méditer sur ce qui vient d'être